all right so now ask yourself if the
binding administration if they really
cared about containing covert well they
have no
problem with these onerous restrictions
on you now if they really cared would
they be letting our borders be
wide open would they be letting illegal
immigrants stroll across the border
before then being released into the
interior of the country
because we're learning tonight that
texas police are discovering that
yeah there's been a high rate of covert
positivity among
illegal immigrants and they're being
sent to local hotels with
little to zero oversight and
zero enforcement none whatsoever and
that's not all because we have an
exclusive report tonight
from our very own investigative reporter
sarah carter
who encountered a group of migrants who
were so sick
crossing the border they needed
immediate medical attention
but again it's not a crisis at the
border according to joe and kamala
watch sarah carter's investigative
report take a look
they've had a little bit of sickness
here he's been sick there's another
child here that's sick
but they've been giving them some
hydration with pedialyte with
electrolytes and some
asthma medication i'm going to get them
walking up and then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to contact border patrol so
that we can get someone down there to
find that girl
that's passed out on the road they've
been walking for more than a month from
honduras
she's feeling very sick obviously she
has an extensive nosebleed i'm
you know going to sit here with her
we've already called
the doctors there's just not enough
people
working manpower to process the need
here at the border i mean i
i don't even know what we need to show
here to express
what's going on here the humanitarian
crisis the national security crisis
the child crisis the migrant crisis
there's just not enough people
to help with the needs of everybody here
investigative reporter sarah carter
joins us now
live again from the border uh this is a
pretty incredible report sarah
for a lot of different reasons not the
least of which is
okay americans now are told being told
that even if you're vaccinated
yeah you got to now start wearing the
mask again but yet
you have joe's cages for kids that are
overcrowded
in the middle of a pandemic one two
uh that we have very little of any
testing and three they're
they're shipping people all over the us
yeah sean i gotta tell you it was
extraordinarily harrowing not just for
me but for the crew
and for the first responders to come
across so many
people that were coming across the
border that were
very ill this woman in particular was
extremely ill
she showed all kinds of signs of not
only heat exhaustion
but possibly covid her two-year-old
daughter was watching her
as this was ongoing and i got to tell
you the first responders
which are law enforcement officers are
border patrol agents
and you know our paramedics our emts
were right there i want you to listen
here to texas texas dps lieutenant
chris olivares he has a lot to say
we did not expect what happened here
today on the rio right i mean
but it happens all the time this woman
was obviously very ill
we don't know what it was maybe he'd
stroke maybe something else her children
were coughing she was
bleeding out profusely you guys are the
first
responders really the first in line to
save someone's life i mean
i don't think if we wouldn't have gotten
out here she may not be here right now
right you're correct so what's that like
so
that's just a perfect example was taking
place now because of these open border
policies that the administration is
is allowing border patrol is overwhelmed
with all the processing and now we're
seeing covet cases
increase especially amongst detainees
that are coming across the river
and that are being in custody with
border patrol we're seeing border patrol
agents that are being affected by covet
because of this
sean i can tell you this i mean the heat
out here is extraordinary the heat index
is over 112 today 111.
it was like that throughout the week we
tried to stay with this woman all the
way up until the time the paramedics
arrived the emt
arrived it took so much time we couldn't
even get an ambulance out there
because where we were at on the border
was so far
from civilization it was very very
difficult border patrol arrived
they assisted emt arrived we were able
to get her out of there and now we don't
even know
how long she'll be separated from her
daughter this is a situation though that
happens every single day
and something that the biden
administration at least
from our part and border patrol agents
are saying is not paying attention to
it's endangering both
u.s lives as well as the migrants who
are crossing sean
all right sarah carter incredible report
and you know great work
a lot of humanity a great humanitarian
effort by you and
and all these first responders uh these
people
we know have even many of them died on
on some ranches uh that are next to the
border
we can't have that happening either hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else